那么大家好
欢迎来到松明讲心理的
这么一个直播间
那么这两天没开播
可能很多朋友还在问对吧
啊怎么不见了呀
怎么停了呀
其实
我们是在准备新的一些课程内容啊
想把这些日子啊
沉淀下来的一些思考
其实想把它整理的更系统对吧
更有逻辑
以后再带给大家
那么今天呢
就算是我们的一次集中的分享吧
也就说
把我这段时间准备的一些核心内容啊
完整的讲给大家听一听好不好
哼哼哼
那么很多朋友经常跟我说
说生活太累了
工作累对吧
感情累包括和家人的关系也累啊
其实说到底不是我们不会过日子对吧
我觉得是
我们总是被一些表象所迷惑了
也有可能是被别人的眼光所绑架了
被一些执念困住了自己
那你说我们这活一辈子
到底该抓的是什么
该放的又是什么
该如何面对钱或者是情
该如何处理和父母的关系
和孩子的关系
包括和自己朋友的关系
为什么有的人喜欢安静对吧
但是比谁都清醒
有的人呢
热情却总是活得很惶恐
有的人看似强硬
但是内心无比的自卑
这些问题
我觉得几乎困扰着我们每一个人
是不是这样
那么今天
我们把它整理成了10个部分啊
我觉得像10堂人生的必修课
那我会一点一点的来给大家做分享啊
那么在这10个主题里边
有关于人性的一些冷知识
有关于钱或者是情的这么一个智慧
也会聊到如何去放松
或者是如何培养能
力的一些具体的方法
和会聊亲子关系啊
人生的一些弯路啊
对吧包括一些知识
一些智慧的区别以及为什么
啊
就是做自己想做的事
对我们来说这么重要
那我也相信
大家一定能从中找到一句话
戳住你当下的困惑甚至
对吧
能够改变你看待生活的这么一个角度
所以今天呃如果说
你也带着一些焦虑和疑问走了进来
那我也希望你能够耐心的待在这
也希望大家能够在其中找到一句话
能够帮你解开此时的心结
或许他们就是你们想要的方向
或者是想要的答案
对吧啊
有什么问题可以打在评论区啊
可以打在评论区
嗯
欢迎大家
老师每天几点上直播间讲课
这是新同学啊
嗯
每天早上几点同学们
我们的直播间是每天早上几点
大家点点这个下方的这个关注啊
然后点一点这个这个我们叫什么来着
叫粉丝团对吧
嗯
对点一下
然后我开播以后啊
这个系统就会自动的提醒给大家啊
对吧点击下方的预约就可以了啊
刚才那位同学对
你看我们同学都告诉你了啊
我们的直播间是早上7点对吧
周日8点
大家都比较熟了啊
感谢大家的关注
感谢大家的关注嗯
hmm
在生活里边
我们常常会误解别人
看到一个人的表象
就轻易的给他下这么一个定义
可其实越是刻意的表现
越能说明背后有一个未被看见的脆弱
你看你在一群人里边
你也许会注意到那个最安静的人
很多人认为他胆小可
能内向
可能不敢开口
但真正的原因是
他早已看透了人情冷暖
沉默并不是退缩
反而我觉得它是一种清醒
因为他明白
没必要用这种喧哗去证明存在
因为真正的力量是内心的安稳
你可能遇见过
喜欢不断倾诉自己悲惨经历的人
他们看似脆弱
但我觉得
其实是习惯在受害者的角度里边
在索取关注
大家觉得是不是
所以我跟大家说过
不要老是把自己变成一个受害者
能理解吗
啊
因为你说的这些话
很有能
很有可能一不小心就变成真的了
是不是这样
你们有没有见过
喜欢不断倾诉自己悲惨遭遇的人
有还是没有啊
有的打个一字来啊
对吧其实他要的是什么
他自己都不知道他要的是什么
这就是人潜意识最可怕的地方
他要的是两个字
大家打一打叫关注
叫做关注
对吧有同学说祥林嫂哼哼哼
说的很对
说的很对啊嗯
抱怨成为他们获取同情
或者是证明价值的一种方式了
我跟你说
并不是说他们没有力量
而是他们不敢直面生活
他只能用这种悲情
来延续别人对自己的目光
所以那些总是过分的热情
甚至有些殷勤到让人不适的人
看似贴心
其实隐藏着巨大的这种不安全感
因为他们害怕被忽视啊
害怕被抛弃
所以不停的迎合表面
对吧笑脸盈盈
嗨啊表面是笑脸盈盈
内心是小心翼翼
说话犀利攻击力很强的人
他总会给人一种强硬的印象
但我告诉大家
实际上他们内
心可能充满着自卑和恐惧
他只有通过先发制人的攻击
才能够掩饰心底的脆弱
他们不是天生尖锐
而是害怕一旦柔软就会被伤害
还有的人总是喜欢用玩笑来贬低别人
有没有就是你以为那是幽默
其实同样也是一种自卑
他们靠贬低别人
来获取这种短暂的优越感
可是一旦独处
我告诉你
他们就会陷入到更深的孤独里边
所以我希望大家
不要只盯着一个人的外在表现
记住每个刻意的背后
都藏着难以启齿的脆弱和需求
真正的理解
不是对表象的评判
真正的理解不是对表象的评判
而是对人性的洞察
所以大家可以把这句话打出来
理解不是对表象的评判
而是对人性的洞察
啊
所以你看
现实就是这个样子
在生活里边是不是有很多啊啊
就当我们看透了表象背后的
这些人心的脆弱
你会发现啊
是每个人
其实都有自己的这么一个执念
是不是人活着一辈子
说到底
我觉得最放不下的其实就是两个字
一个是money
一个是情
就是钱决定了什么
决定了我们生活的安全感
而情
牵动着我们内心的这么一个归属感
这两样东西
几乎就牵扯了
人生大多数的矛盾和挣扎
所以我们接下来来聊一聊
这两个字到底该怎么看
又到底该怎么放
人这一辈子
最放不下的就两个字
钱和情钱是生存的根基
情是心灵的寄托
可是有多少人
一直忙忙碌碌挣扎在这两个字里边
到最后才发现
钱带不走
情留不下
为了钱你看人们起早贪黑
加班熬夜
拼命的透支健康
甚至牺牲陪伴家人的时间
钱的确重要
没有他对吧
生活会寸步难行
但钱我告诉你
他也像无底洞啊
再多你都嫌不够啊
多少人把命搭了进去
换来了一串数字
最后钱还在
命没了
最真正的智慧
是懂得适可而止
钱够养家
够安稳对吧
够支撑日子就好
过了这个度
钱不再是福了
那我再说一遍
过了这个度
钱就不再是福
而是枷锁
记住钱能买到房子
却买不到温暖能买到药
却买不来健康
命只有一条
千万别把命变成赚钱的筹码
为了情人们掏心掏肺
付出所有
期待能换来同样的深情
可现实往往残酷啊
感情这个东西
不是你付出多少
你就能得到多少啊
你越卑微
你就越容易被忽视
你越没有底线
就越容易被伤害
所以感情里边
最难学的不是去爱
而是学会爱的体面
就即使再爱一个人
咱们也要给自己留三分
留给尊严
留给退路
因为只有这样
在你感情崩溃的时候
你才不会被彻底的摧毁
你才有余力去疗愈自己
爱别人之前
先学会爱自己
钱够用就好
情用真就好
别让钱奴役了你
也别让情消耗了你
人生的意义
并不在于拥有多少的财富
也不在于抓住谁不放
而是在于你能不能在拥有的同时
守住自我
在失去里边
依然能够坦然前行
一辈子很短的
所以别被钱困住了你的心
更别被情
更别被被啊
更别被情困住了命
把握好分寸
你才能够活得自由
活得安稳呐
是不是这样
所以这两个东西
就是人心啊
最大的一个牵绊
就是很多时候我们之所以累
为什么不是说你钱不够嘛
对吧不是说你的情不顺嘛
而是因为你太在意别人怎么看你
有再多的钱
只要有两个字叫对比
你就完了
你永远是穷人理解吗
别人一句话可能就能左右咱们的心情
对吧别人的眼光
一个眼光就可以
就可能把你的这个整个生活节奏
给打乱了
那到底怎么做
才能不活在别人的评价里边
活出一个真正的自我呢
欢迎大家啊
来到宋明讲心理的这么一个直播间啊
那接着对吧
是咱们的广告时间啊
大家记得啊
新来的同学
加一下宋明老师的这么一个关注
如果觉得我们讲的对你来说
是有帮助的
同学啊
加一下咱们这个频道的关注啊
加完关注以后不要忘了把灯牌亮一亮
好不好啊
感谢大家的礼物啊
大家把灯牌亮一亮
感谢大家的分享啊
感谢瑞霞的关注啊
感谢印尼的分享啊
大家可以把我们的这个直播间啊
也分享给你周围
你觉得有需要的同同同学
或者是朋友
好不好啊
嗯
在这个世界上
其实你无论怎么做
总会有人对你指指点点
对吧你穿漂亮的衣服哎
有人会说你炫耀啊
那你穿简单的衣服呢
有人是觉得你寒酸
你表达真实的想法
他又说你太直接
不懂分寸
你说我不说呗
我选择沉默呗
他要嘲讽你胆小没
主见你努力奋斗
他嫌你功利
你说那我偶尔停下来休息呢
哎他又说你懒惰不上进
你看
这就是人心复杂
就别人的嘴巴
永远是解不开的锁
他们习惯用自己的眼光
去丈量别人的人生
但可笑的是什么
我跟你们说
很多的评判并不基于事实
而只是他内心的这种偏见
和这种投射啊
如果说你把你自己的人生
交给别人的嘴巴来掌控
你就会永远活在疲惫
和这种自我怀疑里边
你今天迎合了这么一群人
我告诉你
你明天又得迎合另外一群人
到最后你就不再是自己了
而是无数人意见拼凑出来的影子
所以真正的成熟是什么
就是要学会在喧哗中守住自我
别人眼光是别人的事
你的生活才是你的事
那些对你品头论足的人
不会替你承担痛苦的
也不会替你走完你的人生坎坷
你的人生
是你独自的修行
所以
请学会忽略那些毫无意义的议论
别人怎么看你
一点都不重要
重要的是什么
你是否问心无愧
是否走自己想走的路
哪怕这个世界嘲讽你
误解你只要你内心安稳
只要你知道自己的方向
你就没有走错
所以
记住一句话只要你对得起自己的初心
对得起更高层次的良知和信念
谁在乎别人怎么想啊
对吧活得自在
不是因为没有人说闲话
而是你终于明白
别人的嘴管不了你的人生
来我们把这句话打出来别人的嘴
管不了我的人生
嗯
对吧别人的嘴管不了我的人生
就这么简单嗯啊
当我们不再被这种外界牵着鼻子走
你的内心我告诉你就会获得两个字
这两个字很重要很重要
叫做自由
自由是吧
哈哈
但问题来了呀
那很多人一旦开始为自己而活
他就会紧绷
是不是这样
他会很他会怕自己做不好啊
可是真正的高手
我告诉你
他往往不是紧张用力
他是什么
他是一种放松的状态
松弛
所以为什么我经常说
放松才是最强大的底气
ah
嗯
是不是很多人认为高手之所以厉害
是因为他们对时刻
是因为他们时刻紧绷
全力以赴
但是我告诉你
恰恰相反
真正的高手往往在关键的时候最放松
但凡你处在这种紧张状态
我告诉你
你绝对发挥不出来最好的水平
因为紧张会让你的身体僵硬啊
会让你的思维受限呐
注意力只会被陷在某一个点上
反而失去了全局的掌控力
你越想控制一切
你就越容易被慌乱啊
你就越容易被慌乱牵着走
而当你放松下来
哎你才能够调动起心理对吧
哎你才能调动起这种身体
和心智中所有的资源
那么有一位心理学家叫吉利根老师
他说过一句很深刻的话
他说什么呢
他说我们身体的每一份紧张
都和一个念头紧紧的相连
大家想想是不是这么一个道理
你身体的每一份紧张都和一个念头
有没有这个念头是一个执念呢
当你心里想着我不能失败
你的身体就会立刻的收紧
当你在意别人怎么看我
你的呼吸
就会变浅
你的肩膀就会变硬
你看
一个念头就能牵动全身的肌肉和情绪
那久而久之
我们就会把自己困在无形的牢笼里边
既耗尽了能量
也封锁了你的潜能
可是当你有意识的放松身体哎
我告诉你
这个事情就会发生微妙的变化
深吸一口气
慢慢的吐出来
放松你的肩膀
让僵硬的手指舒缓的展开
感受脚踩在地上的踏实
我告诉你
这些细微的动作啊
实际上在告诉大家
对吧实际上在告诉你的大脑
可以了
你是安全的
身体的放松
意味着
你正在放下那个紧咬不放的念头
当念头松开
紧张自然消散
我告诉你
此时你的感官会更敏锐的
你的这种创造力和直觉
就会被激发出来
就像一位音乐家在舞台上
真正动人的演奏
往往来自于忘我的放松
就像一位运动员在赛场上
临门一脚的神奇发挥
也不是源自于用力过猛
而是源自于全身心的轻盈与专注
高手之所以是高手
并不是因为他们比常人更紧张
而是因为他们比常人更会放松
他们知道啊
只有身心合一的放松
才是掌控全局的状态
所以
当你发现你自己陷入到紧张
你不妨提醒一下自己
放松就是力量
你不是因为紧绷才成功的
而是因为你在放松中
找回了本该属于你自己的
全部的能量和智慧
这个才是核心
来我们大家打一句话
放松就是力量
每个同学都打一打来
是吧放松就是高手的心
法你问我宋明老师什么叫高手心法
但是我告诉你
你真正的要把你的人生走顺呐
还需要一些具体的能力啊来支撑你
就像房子需要地基
对吧人生也需要一些基本功嘛
我给大家说三种底层的这么一个能力
不是天赋啊
不是天赋
每个人都可以练得出来的好不好
每个人都能练得出来
we来说一说
hmm
就是人这一生
你要活得通畅
你要活得通透
离不开三种能力
它们啊不是空洞的大道理
而是你每天都用得到的基本功
越早学会
越早受益
第一种能力好好说话
大家打字来好好说话
会说话的人
他不是嘴皮子利索
他是懂得分寸
对家人对吧
说话温和
因为一句带刺的话
可能就在亲密关系里边会留下裂缝
那对外人呢
说话你要得体啊
因为语言就是你的名片
生活里边很多的矛盾
并不是事情的本身
而是一句话说的太急太重
你比方说夫妻吵架
不是因为谁洗碗
而是因为那句你真懒
把这个火药桶给点燃了
所以学会这种柔和的表达
就能够让关系越来越顺畅
那么这是第一个
第二种能力情绪稳定
人生啊十有八九都是不如意的
有的人在小事上就会失控
对吧堵个车呀
迟到了呀
被误解了呀
但坏情绪从来都解决不了问题的
他只会让局面更糟
情绪稳定不是说你没有情绪
而是你能够做情绪的主人
当愤怒来了
哎学会停一停
而不是立刻甩脸色
当焦虑来了
你能够看到它而不
是被它推着走
所以真正的强者
不是从不跌倒
而是不会轻易的被情绪打败
第三种能力自我陪伴
大家打字来自我陪伴
人生本质上就是一场孤独的旅行
父母会老
伴侣有自己的世界
朋友也会渐渐的疏远
到最后能够一直陪着你的
我告诉你
只有你自己
所以你要学会一件很重要的事
就是学会跟自己相处
一个人吃饭旅行
你也能自在
在独处当中找到宁静
而不是恐慌
自我陪伴
他不叫孤单
而是和自己做朋友
我跟你说
内心安稳的人
他不会把全部期待压在别人的身上
也不会因为孤独而慌乱
没有人陪伴的时候
他依然能够活得热气腾腾
这就是最大的底气啊
所以好好说话是对外的能力
情绪稳定是对内的能力
自我陪伴是对心灵的能力
你就练好这3种本事
你就能在人生的风雨里边
走得更稳更远啊
如果你们觉得有收获的来
咱们打一个7字来
是吧这三个能力也不难吧哈哈
不知道怎么好好说话的同学
看看咱们的沟通课去啊
把我们的沟通课看一看
所以
要不断的去学这种沟通的一些技术啊
学这种情绪管理啊
包括这种自我陪伴啊
对吧
人际关系里边还有一个很大的陷阱
这个陷阱叫啥呢
你们知不知道叫什么
这个陷阱叫操心
太操心
很多人一辈子都很操心
你们知道吧
啊我们总会觉得
爱就是管很多对吧
所以就会很操心嘛
可事实上呢
我告诉你
过度的操心
反而变成了
另外一种
不好的
那我们该怎么放手呢
啊
嗯
来没有加关注的加加关注来啊
我就是操心的人
对啊哈哈
你以为就你啊
我们直播间一堆操心的人
每天操这个心操那个心
是不是这样啊
别太操心孩子
也别太操心父母
更别把亲朋好友的事
都揽在自己的肩上
你得明白了
大多数的操心
最后都变成了徒劳
为什么
因为每个人都有自己的三世因果啊
过去式的因
决定了他此生一部分的境遇
你此生的选择
又会影响未来的结果
谁也替代不了谁
谁也绕不过去
我跟你说
你再怎么焦虑
也没办法帮你的孩子改命
也不能替你的父母延寿
更无法替朋友挡灾
你说你担心孩子学习不好
那是他该走的因缘呐
他未必就此沉沦呐
哎或许能够闯出你想不到的精彩的
是不是
你说你害怕父母衰老
可这就是生命的自然规律啊
他们的坚韧和福报
早已经种在了他们自己的因果里边
你说你想替亲朋好友避开这些弯路
但我告诉你
有些坎就是命运里边注定要撞上的
有些苦头是不尝就不会醒悟的
这个世界上最没用的事
就是不停的给年轻人讲经验
你讲一万句
不如让他摔一跤
眼泪能让人懂得珍惜
后悔能逼人成长
南墙才是最严厉的老师啊
所以记住
人生该走的弯路
一米都少不了
很多人以为爱就是我要紧紧的拽住
但是呢你越拽的紧
流失的越快
越是事事操心
你的心就会越疲惫
就像手里的沙子
拽紧了全部漏光
松开了哎
反而能够留住一些
就像养花
天天浇水
不是爱是害
最后呢只会烂根
做人其实只有三件事
自己的事
尽力就好
别人的事
尊重就行
老天的事
接受便是
孩子有孩子的路
父母有父母的服务
亲人只是同乘一辆巴士的旅客
我跟你说
到站了有人上车
也有人下车
我们能做的
只是珍惜同路的时光啊
所以大家记住
过度操心就是一种温柔的绑架
放手才是高级的慈悲
因为每个人
都要走完属于自己的三世因果
所以在所有的关系里边
最容易被操心裹挟的
我告诉你是什么
就是四个字
叫亲子关系
就是很多父母总是忍不住对孩子操心
对孩子控制
但你不知道啊
孩子才是最无条件爱你的人
你只有理解这一点
我告诉你
亲子关系才能够回归这种温柔和纯粹
那么接着我们来聊一聊
孩子和父母之间最深的这种爱
是什么啊
欢迎来到
宋明讲心理的这么一个直播间啊
没有加关注的同学
大家加一加咱们的关注来啊
对如果想看我们直播回放的啊
我们我们加入我们的会员啊
加入我们的频道会员
就可以不断的啊
无限制的观看我们的这么一个回播啊
直播回放啊
点击宋明老师的头像
点击会员就可以了啊
自己的事
尽力就好啊
尽力就好
对
我们直播间有多少是宋明老师的会员
我们频道会员的同学有没有
有的打个一字来我看
看来
就是当你难以克制
对孩子发脾气
你先听听这段话来
很多时候
你看咱们心情不好
情绪积压
便控制不了自己的脾气
孩子可能只是做错了一件小事
那我们却可能忍不住对他吼叫啊
甚至指个骂打他呀
那更矛盾的是
当孩子情绪激动大发脾气的时候
我们却要求他立刻冷静
甚至用批评和惩罚来压制他
你们觉得这是不是很讽刺啊
就是我们自己做不到的事
却理直气壮的要求孩子去做到
我们可以因为一件小事而心烦意乱
却要求孩子永远懂事乖巧冷静
那更令人对吧
那更令人心酸的是什么
就孩子在被责骂以后
他并不会像成年人那种心怀怨恨
他反而会非常努力的去讨好父母
试着用笑脸拥抱
甚至忍让来缓和这么一个气氛
因为他们害怕失去父母的爱呀
所以他常常会压抑自己的委屈
所以他会常常压抑自己的委屈
选择迎合
你想一想
在这个世界上
有谁会在一次次被责骂以后
依然不离不弃啊
有谁会在一次次被误解以后
依然努力的讨好你啊
答案只有一个
就是你的孩子
人们常说母爱是伟大的感情
但当你真正成为父母之后
你会发现
孩子对你的爱
其实比你对孩子的爱更纯粹
母爱里边有责任有焦虑有期待
有对未来的担忧
而孩子的爱
单纯到只有依赖与信任
你可能因为工作生活的压力忽略他
但他始终把你当成全世界
所以
下次当你要发脾气的时候
先停一停
想一想对吧
眼前这个
孩子可能是你此生最深的牵挂
也是这个世界上最爱你的人
别让一时的情绪伤了那个最单纯的心
学会温柔
学会耐心
不是因为孩子完美
是因为他们值得的
所以很多时候
你看亲子关系让我们就明白了
爱需要真心
而成长需要的是另外一个东西
我们叫亲身经历
教育也是如此啊
我不是说书本上的知识不重要
书本上的知识固然重要
但真正能改变命运的
是你经历过的智慧
所以智慧和知识到底有什么区别呢
我们来给大家讲一讲啊
知识可以背诵
但是智慧你必须经历
有人说过一句意味深长的话
就当你把学校里边学的知识
都忘掉的时候
留下的东西才叫做教育
为什么
因为学校教给咱们的大多是知识
而人生尤其你要创业啊
你需要的是智慧
不是知识
知识是什么
是书本上的定理公式
是被整理过的经验
是前人总结下来的结果
他固然重要
能帮你对吧
他虽然重要
能够帮你好好的
对吧打好这个思维的底子
给你看待世界的基本框架
但如果说你只会背书记笔记
却从不敢在真实的世界里边试错
那我告诉你
那些知识终究只能停留在纸面
而智慧是什么
智慧这个东西
是你用自己的脚步走出来的
是你在现实的撞击当中磨练出来的
智慧是一个活的知识
大家打一打字来
活的知识
他不会只停留在脑子里边
而是能够灵活的应用
在各种的场景里边
你看一个创业者
他要做决策
他不可能翻开课本找答案是不是
那真正的答案是什么
往往就藏在市场的变化里边
藏在客户的反馈里边
甚至
藏在你一次次失败之后的顿悟里边
文化好的人
大多都是玩出来的
他们懂得在各种体验里边去吸收养分
举一反三
读书好的人
大多数都是勤奋出来的
他们能坐得住
能够熬得住
靠汗水积累成绩
而创业做得好的人
则往往具备三个特质一情商
二智慧三勇气
情商高他能看懂人心啊
懂得在关键的时刻如何沟通啊
如何去合作啊
那有智慧
能够让他透过现象看到本质啊
在复杂的局面里边
他能找到出路啊
勇气足哎
让他敢于试错
他不怕摔倒
也从头不怕从零再来
所以学校能教你知识
但教不来真正的智慧的
只有当你跳出课堂
走进社会
把所学的忘掉
放下这个框架
你才才是真正的创造
所以记住知识是起点
智慧才是终点
我们把这句话打出来知识是起点
智慧是终点
早上好啊早上好
知识是起点
智慧才是重点啊
在创业的路上
决定你能走多远的
不是你记得住多少的定义
而是你能否把书本里的知识
转化为生命里边真正的智慧啊
所以
这个就是知识和智慧不一样的地方
他们的区分你就更能够清楚的
对吧
选择这么一个属于自己的生活方式了
所以活得精彩
不只是背书
更是要活出方法
我跟你们分享7个
不管哪不管
就是当你不断地遇到质疑不
断地遇到误解甚至打击的时候
记住7个
不管怎样
第一个不管怎样
都要去做
别人或许不讲道理
常常固执武断
甚至自以为是
那你要宽恕他们
因为他们的偏见
不该成为你停止前进的理由啊
第二个不管怎样
都要善良
善良给对人
即便你善良
别人可能会说你虚伪
动机不纯
但善良从来都不是为了取悦谁呀
而是你心中的光
别人怎么想是他们的事
你要守住属于自己的本性
第三个不管怎样
都要成功
成功会让你收获掌声
但也会带来嫉妒和敌意
有人因为你的成就而靠近你
但也有人因为你的光芒而疏远你
但不要犹豫
既然你有梦想
你就要去实现呐
第四个不管怎样不管怎样
都要诚实
真诚无敌
真诚坦率的人可能会被欺骗
可能会被利用
但虚伪带不来真正的安全感
唯有诚实才让你活得心安
第五不管怎样
都要坚持
你辛苦经营的一切
也许会在一夜之间被摧毁
但我告诉你
这不是放弃的理由
而是再次出发的力量
生命的意义不在于结果永恒
而是在于过程真诚
第六个不管怎样
都要快乐
当你找到安宁与快乐
有人可能会嫉妒你
甚至想要摧毁你
可快乐不是他们的
它属于你
别让别人的阴霾遮住你自己的晴空啊
第七个不管怎样
都要行善
就是你今天所做的善事
可能明天别人就忘记
但这不重要
因为你做的是对的
自己的一种善意
所以最后
把你最好的一部分可以献给这个
世界或许你付出的一切
别人永远不会满足
甚至无人感激
但不管怎样
你还是要把自己最美好的一面
交给生活
因为你终究会明白
这一切说到底
是你与上帝之间的事
而不是你与别人之间的事
当我们掌握了这种活法
你会发现哎
人生看似复杂
其实都有一个最底层的逻辑
就是善
或者是真诚
你对别人好
看似无声无息
但迟早一定会回到你自己身上
你如果说我每天都在算计
结果往往也被消耗殆尽
所以真正的风水
不是在屋宅的朝向
不是在命盘八字
而是你每天的动心起念呐
所以为什么我们说
行善才是人这一辈子最大的风水呢
生活里边
总有人劝你去找个大师算算命
对吧仿佛命运能够被几句话决定
我劝你一句
别算命为什么
因为算命背后的逻辑
就是一种混沌系统
大家把这四个字打一打
混沌系统
人类面对混沌系统有两种
第一种呢
我们叫一级混沌系统
我给你们举个例子哎
这个时候广州会不会下雨
那我管啊
那我跟你说
不管你猜是下或者不下
最终的结果和你没有关系
因为天气自有规律
你的预测不会改变它
那么第二种
我们叫二级混沌系统
你比方说明天的股市会不会涨
那这就复杂了呀
如果今天某一位专家说
哎呀明天一定会涨
那大量人听信以后
他真的会一拥而上的去买呀
结果
这个市场就会被大家的行为推着走
涨跌会被预测
会被影响
这就叫二级混
沌系统因为人的预期和行为
会改变最终的结果
我跟你说
算命就是如此
一旦你听了所谓的大师的预言
你的行为就会被他操控
你比方说他说你明年财运不好
哎你可能在投资工作的时候
你会畏手畏脚
结果呢真的错失了机会
他说你你的因缘在西方
你就会刻意的去找这种迹象
忽略掉本来就适合你的人
所以最后你的人生轨迹
被他的一段话牵着走
你不是真的活自己
而是你活在算命的剧本里面了
你再想想历史
同学们
如果说风水这东西真能决定一切
那么历代皇帝用的都是最好的风水局
为什么朝代还会更替啊
为什么最强大的宫殿
最后还是会被最普通的农民起义
给推翻呢
如果命运真能算
帝王贵权又怎会失势呢
所以真正决定你命运的
从来不是所谓的天机
而是你每天的选择
你播种善意
就会收获善意
你努力奋斗
就会有机会靠近成功
所以别把希望寄托在算命上
但行好事
莫问前程
行善就是最好的风水
努力就是最稳的命运
命运不会写死在别人的嘴里边
它始终握在你自己的手里边啊